[Music]  Khloe Kardashian's friend seemingly  targets Tristan Thompson amid his  cheating allegations on Tuesday Khadijah  hack McCray whose twin sister is Chloe's  bestie Malika Haqq took to Instagram  with this cryptic message that read  quote the best thing a father can do for  his children is to love their mothers  this comes after video surfaced of what  looked like Tristan kissing another  woman in a nightclub and smoothing  really fast for me  Chloe is due to give birth to her first  child any day now but a source told ET  to not expect the mom-to-be to make any  statements about Tristan right now  [Music]  ZT previously reported Chloe's friends  are shocked and didn't see this coming  adding quote they seem to be in a really  good place I'm gonna figure it all out I  promise you  [Music]  [Applause]